hallo mein name ist luca und wir spielen
heute mal wieder akinator wir sind auf
der website mein gott hier steht vor ihm
das ist doch nicht wickeln ist dass das
chaos ist so ist das der fall wie aus
dem pokémon video hier unten steht auch
wieder dass ich wieder gespielt wurde
aber das ist ja echt und fassbar das ist
als ob nur hier dieses spiel spielt mir
wurde geschrieben dass ich
hunderttausend mal gespielt wurde bei
agitator das testen wir jetzt ich bin 19
jahre alt blicke auf spielen ist eine
theorie youtube berühmt gewordenen jahr
trägt eine figur männerkleidung ja hat
eine freeware pop stars mitgemacht was
war nochmal popstars ich würde mal sagen
nein ist er nicht nur ein engel
eigentlich schon ich fünf mal sagen
wahrscheinlich hat damit nicht nur in
den 90er jahren ein kind gespielt denn
nicht nur in minecraft bahro drei jahre
hat er nicht wir glauben dass ca
blonde haare kannst du vielleicht
deutsch lernen ja hat sie sagt deine
figur bei jüdischen ja ich sage hallo
mein name ist luca und hey wer hat
dieses bild eingereicht das bild ist
falsch ich will wieder das was andere
bild da reinkommen aber okay ja es
stimmt und ich wurde 125 1853 mal was
hat ihr bekloppt ich wurde 125000 mal
gespielt wie viel das ist ich versuche
jetzt mal justin bieber zu finden weil
justin bieber ja auch schon star als der
der glaube ich auch ein paar mal
gespielt wurde deswegen versuchen wir
jetzt mal justin bieber zu finden hat
dann etwas mit spielen zu tun nein ist
eine figur ausländische
ursprungs jahres die figur asiaten 1 1
figo russischen ein hatte eine figur
schon mal ein konzept geben ja die
werden wir in deutschland hat er eine
freundin namens kati hat er eine
freundin ein hatte eine figur etwas mit
liebe zu tun ja hatten wir schon mal
probleme mit der polizei
ich denke an justin bieber okay jetzt
schauen wir mal wie oft justin bieber
gespielt wurde
wir haben mehr als doppelt so viele
place wie justin bieber ich versuche
jetzt mal grund zu finden weil ich denke
dass der so auf deutschland ebene
gesehen ja der erfolgreichste youtuber
ist denke ich deswegen schauen wir mal
wie viele
er hat er ein freund namens julian hatte
er schon mal hier eingesehen ja kommt
aus dem kosovo
geblieben ist haben einige weibliche
nein kommt eine because the cronk ob er
ja mach deine schule space of konnte ja
ich denke angriffsfläche crange ok
spieleproduzenten letztlich schauen wir
mal krank wurde
ok wurde doppelt so viel gespielt wie
ich okay gut
ich weiß gar nicht mehr wählen wir in
der letzten folge alles gesucht hatten
die verlinke ich euch mal hier
da hatten wir glaube ich auch ueli balu
vitello mich sonst noch irgendwas mir
wurde allerdings gesagt das macht den
pokémon video was sich hochgeladen hatte
das feuer riegel eingereicht wurde trägt
eine figur männerkleidung nein hat seine
figuren handy nein ich werde das mit
musik zu tun nein gehört deine figur ist
dieser frage gibt doch die figur mir
gehört ok ja das stimmt existiert deine
figur wirklich nein ist eine figur ten
box zu sehen nein war deine figur gut
mit konkreter befreundet gibt es da eine
figur wirklich
wahrscheinlich nicht hat er schon mal
geheiratet
nein ist eine figur leicht an
folgerichtig ganz schnell athletisch
nein dass seine figuren youtuber nein
hat einen schwanz seine figuren youtube
ist der dom das hat er gerade ist
gefragt nein ich habe gesagt meine figur
hat nichts mit nintendogs zu tun ich sag
mal einfach das ist balu ist und beruf
40 40.000 40.000 mal wurdest du gespielt
ich versuche jetzt immer noch voll regel
zu finden hat eine schülerin handy nein
hat eine kleine ja ist eine figur
klassischer abstammung ist dafür ein
hund nein das sind wir ja damit seine
figur aus einem spielen ja kommt eine
geburt ein horrorspiel von nine von
religionsgemeinschaften ein konzert hat
was mit einer figur wie man ja mein gott
es hat tatsächlich kaum kraft das
pokemon erkannt all das was geht denn ab
okay das ist voll auch schon 12.000 mal
ich sag mal seid ihr denn noch zu retten
das ist einfach nur noch heftig man mir
wurde außerdem auch in die kommentare
geschrieben dass mein malaga fucking
staub eingereicht wurde alter hat deine
figur etwas mit feuer zu tun nein wurde
deine figur youtube sind nur ein tier
nein trägt eine figur männerkleidung
nein ist denn die figur aus holzen nein
hat eine besonders angetan nein das
steht damit kurz plastik presse für
augen macht nein meine figur spielt
nicht in minecraft ja sie gehört von
crafter sie macht als wenn man staub
kämpfe machen würde gegen anderen stau
walter deine figur mehrere haarfarben
wie ein hund nicht ein wasser zu tun
gedenken an vitello nein hat er nicht
nur ein tierisches aussehen nein kommt
eine figur aus einem kollegen geschenkt
deutschland-achter ist die gruppe in
flaschen
ich würde mal sagen jaja meine sich nur
ist grau ja sie hat etwas mit kontrasten
staub passt eigentlich auch in meine
tasche ich denke an stau blutstau mir
wurde auch letztens bei facebook
geschrieben dass diese ganzen sachen
schon eingereicht wurden
da steht contractors zunge kontrakt am
monitor kontrakt das t shirt kongress
stuhl con stuhl komplett schwarze wand
wie ist das euer ernst später gibt es
immer eine halbe wohnung bei akinator zu
finden
ich würde aber sagen freunde das war es
heute hier von akinator ich wollte
wirklich nur noch mal schauen ob ihr
wirklich vori und staubig und sonnen
schickt eingereicht hat mann und ich
wurde hunderttausend mal gespielt also
das ist übelst krank also wenn ihr die
pokémon folge mit folgen noch nicht
gesehen habe fand ich die hier oben das
ist eigentlich ganz cool dass man das so
verlinken kann dann muss ich nicht so